thank you
[Music]
oh this story might be the favorite of
the day
you guys might like it
can't wait this happened in a city
called Katie in a state called Tejas two
burglars they came up with this genius
plan to break into a house dressed up as
cops as soon as they entered the house
one burglar immediately got scared by
the other thought he was a cop and shot
him
oh my God
oh [__] it's a cop yeah great
so what happened dang he's getting
[__] you shot a cop
is that intent to shoot a police officer
impersonation yeah both
murdered and both of them are going down
for impersonation because his actions
are also what a cop probably would do so
then uh when they got in there and this
debacle happened the people living in
the house saw it happen [__] they're
like what the [__] is happening and so
we're moving itself when burglar one
shoots the other cops looking dude and
he goes down
this guy he's the guy who shot him just
like super shocked and then he drops the
gun this guy was shot staggers out and
escapes and then left this dude sit down
in there the homeowner guys picked up
the drop gun and they killed that guy oh
[__] so they killed the cop they killed
the fake other cop oh he I wonder how
they knew I would be so shocked he
killed a cop it was like one of the two
sons that was living there picked the
picked the gun up and shot the other
fake you gotta lock them all up dude
that's intent to kill a police officer
if I saw two cops shooting at each other
in my living room I wouldn't even have
the thought to pick up a gun and shoot
the cop yeah I'd be like what the [__]
is happening they were dressed in like
not just police uniforms they were just
in riot gear that's so funny so they
look like extreme cops yeah
I I think happened is the the one they
both go in and this guy's like I'm not
splitting this [__] money with this
guy oh it's like a Canaan Lynch
situation you know what I mean that
early in the game
he jumped the car before the robber he
got two three before they got the loot
yeah so it's not even about shooting the
your partner it's like oh [__] we didn't
Rob them yet ah [__] I didn't get the
bag yet [__] son of a oh [__] and then
he gets shot because they want you to
like make the crime scene looks like all
scattered they wanted to throw off the
scent so he had to shoot him right then
and there in the kitchen how crazy is
that situation imagine seeing that go
down who's watching TV and then yeah and
that's more interesting police and he's
like oh [__] he shoots the other police
police
what the [__] I thought we was the bad
guys
they sound like [__] 90s doofuses
yeah I really think the cops got their
so fast too yeah
simultaneous responds to the crime
that's what he says he's your bang oh
man you guys are fast
how did you think that that you Ricky I
said I was going through the front yeah
and we know that he thought this if the
guy is now dead didn't get to talk to
the cat
maybe they heard it the guys that live
there oh they're like holy so he says
out loud maybe he's like holy [__] to
cops are here he looks at the homeowner
goes there's a cop in here
he goes oh you shot me right yeah
there's no there's no account of what
the dialogue was but that how many
burglars was he picked up there got and
shot him with it one dead one one
getaway car though okay get away card so
two guys go in like this they look at
each other this guy thinks that's a real
cop shoots him got two sons in the house
or just looking at it like what the [__]
is this this guy who shot oh my God
drops this gun how do you explain that
to the guy in the getaway car what
happened nobody showed up at the getaway
car
they're all [__] bleeding out the cow
he's bleeding yeah he's coming out
bleeding gets in the getaway car they
take off right getaway car driver shoots
the guy coming out
shot a cop don't worry we're all clear
out here get away drivers wearing cop
outfit too looks in the [__] mirror
it's like oh [__]
wow oh my God that's great
us they put a [__] American flag over
the casket
keeps going fake everything they do the
salute and everything he deserves it bro
that's a [__]
little brother also like what a story to
have like a part of your life I know
yeah I'm sure like you're distraught by
what you had to do too but at the same
time but also like it's a two stooges
moment that's a good scenario though if
you're the homeowner you're like hey we
dodged the bullet that was pretty good
what were they doing like did they break
in and they're playing Xbox like dude
were they like having a dinner you know
it doesn't say they were just but they
were in the house and seeing it happen
that's wild dude it's really funny I
wonder how rich they were or like
because it's a pretty big operation for
what like are they trying to get a lot
of money did they say did they know
there was a safe you know so many
questions because like it sounds like a
really big
like like a whole whole elaborate thing
you know I don't think these two idiots
had any strategic plan no because what's
the point of showing up pretending to be
cops if you're going to go in blasting
anyway
shouldn't you go in there pretend to be
constantly we got a situation we're
going to look in your jewelry cabinet
and stuff yeah I don't most Cops start
with a knock on the door because that's
why you have a disguise right why do
that if they just dress like aliens
right if they come in with shields and a
[__] helmet I'd be like the [__] are
you doing in here maybe they just
thought the right gear was just like
armored and then they once they got a
good look at each other he's like oh
that's good they bought it from like
Party City though yeah yeah no way it's
legit there's no way it's gonna die now
it probably says Security on it yeah
it's plastic it's really hard to kind of
rationalize like they have the real
uniform so they had to buy the Party
City male stripper cop uniforms and they
came in that way right gear yeah
slutting it's [__] cop here yeah his
belly's showing
yeah dude that's nice it's not [__]
without the fishnet yeah you gotta have
the fish now yeah it's really weird
because it really says that as soon as
they broke in they immediately started
shooting
so it's like
the same second you break in a house you
think that's a cop and you start
shooting it's so funny maybe it was
always supposed to get rid of his
partner right there
to like leave them at the scene and have
one person be like the Joker do you know
what the fight is so there was one
getaway driver right so they drove with
they drove there together they left
together and one went through the back
door went through the front and then
they just
shot each other like they've never seen
each other before yeah it's like it's
like a bad uh Airsoft match
Home Alone did they both die alone [__]
no they didn't both die but one guy the
guy who's left like takes his plastic
badge to a lake
he has the emotional distress of a Cause
[Music]
he throws it and then it like does it
because it's like plastic paper make the
lake he has to keep picking it up in his
airpods he's listening to Sarah
McLaughlin I will remember you
Gonzalez you were a good man police
station and he gives his plastic
handcuffs and his [__] badge and he
goes I'm out plastic handcuffs I quit
I can't do this anymore I lost my
[__] partner on Thurman
he's like commits from now on I work
alone
I can't have a partner don't you
Partners Chief I don't do Partners
anymore she's like who the [__] are you
hey you're the guy that [__] got away
yeah I don't know if they caught the
dude uh the other two guys that fled yet
no it's because the other two guys were
shooting themselves remember oh right
they're dead they're dead now they can't
find them because they're have you guys
ever seen the dear sister SNL sketch
yeah Andy Samberg dear sister yeah we're
it's like it was like making fun of oh
yeah is that the [__] yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah what you say yeah
[Laughter]
that was their finale and then they
parodied that it was so funny but it
works on its own you have to know that
I don't know what happened to them I
know huh did you see SNL I mean Super
off topic but you saw how SNL covered
the try guys thing how these parodies
miss the [__] Mark like oh really so
bad it's another [__] assault on
internet people remember how that [__]
you said
you still thinks it's the thing
yeah they parodied the try guys of like
video where they were like oh but about
their I can't believe my friends they
just made them look like they're not a
real company and they called them uh
pranksters like they're prank YouTubers
they probably get more reviews than
[__] us they do SNL is averaging 3
million an episode now how many uniques
who knows well there's a lot of [__]
yeah yeah but just say those are two
recipes apparently it's about to end I
heard SNL the Keenan Thompson said that
basically at the 50th Anniversary which
is in like two years I think or three
years that's it he thinks it'll end I'm
surprised it's still going I mean dude
it's pretty it's pretty rough it's wrong
no one really watches television but
senior citizens right it's just their
view on the world is so like they really
refuse to accept like modern [__]
entertainment like they're still talking
[__] on internet based comedy like yeah
because their Their audience is probably
like Boomers and older but even then
those people all watch people on the
internet 10 years ago though like when
people are hanging out in rooms like
this you're showing each other SNL clips
or whatever like 15 years ago right yeah
but now every time I'm in here you guys
are showing videos from all other places
not SNL it's never SNL I don't think you
guys have ever played or people that
used to be on SNL that did their own
[__] and it's like like Shane gills yeah
Tom Robin ever since they've misused the
[__]
um Good Neighbor dudes oh yeah dude the
Good Neighbor dudes were so funny well
like that's how you knew they were out
of touch when they hired those guys and
just shout them I was like oh all that
guy's [__] they missed it they did yeah
they did yeah
foreign